SPEAKER 1: We are lucky to
have Romain Trouble, Executive
Director of the Tara
Expedition Foundation
who will present
the full initiative
and come back on their
major explorations.
And then, in the second
part, Colomban de Vargas,
Director of the Station
Biologique de Roscoff,
and coordinator of the
Tara Ocean Expedition.
He will use his
scientist glasses
to present their past
discoveries and innovative way
of research.
Let's watch a quick video now
to better know about Tara.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SOUND OF OCEAN WAVES]
[END PLAYBACK]
So let's welcome on
stage Romain Trouble,
Director of Tara Expedition.
[APPLAUSE]
ROMAIN TROUBLE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Romain.
I'm a sailor.
I sailed America's cup twice
in my life when I was younger.
And I also studied biology
when I was younger.
Now, I am old and 40 years old.
But I'm heading
Tara since 15 years
now as Etienne Bourgois, the
President of the foundation.
We study the ocean.
I'm a sailor.
We are sailors.
We're also scientists,
as [? Johan ?] told you.
We are all together on
the spaceship Earth,
across the universe, at
millions of kilometers an hour.
And we barely know a few
things about this planet.
She's blue.
When you ask all the astronauts,
and I asked Thomas Pesquet
recently, how's the
planet from the sky?
He said, it's blue.
It's a blue planet.
And 70% of the planet
is made of ocean--
huge, it will change with the
atmosphere, a huge playground
for sailors, of course.
But if you take off all
the water of the planet,
and you want to put
it in a sphere--
just to give you an
idea of the volume--
this is the air we breathe.
The atmosphere we
put in the sphere,
the sphere is this size.
And if you do the same with
all the water of the planet,
this is the ocean water--
very, very tiny ball of
1,400 kilometers in diameter.
The tiny dots here
is the fresh water,
and the smaller dots
is drinkable water.
And our life depends on
this small ball of ocean.
When you breathe, when you
get proteins from the ocean,
the CO2 is stored in
this ocean mainly.
So this is really your
life support system.
So on Tara, we try to take you
on a trip, take the planet,
take humanity on a trip on
science, discover the planet,
try to understand its
fates, where we go on this.
We try to share that with
as many people as we can
through the media,
through the Google,
through YouTube,
through the networks.
In many places we
go in the world,
we've been visiting about 65
countries over the last 10
years, which is a big trip.
Of course, we share that
with kids in the schools,
mainly French-speaking
schools today,
but we are now developing
curricula for overseas.
We also teach the
southern countries
how to go in the ocean, how
to set up scientific boats,
how to understand, how to
use the richness of the ocean
for their behavior, for their
economy, for their development.
And this is a very
strong commitment
we've got since two years now.
And also, as
[? Johan ?] told you,
we are putting some scientists
on ocean at the UN every three,
four months to teach as well.
The people, the kids,
the southern countries,
and the states, and
the negotiators.
So over the last 15 years--
soon 15 years-- we
did many projects.
But we'll meet four of them.
And I will try to explain
to you what we did
and why we did that.
We did one 10 years ago on
the climate in the Arctic.
We did another one four
years in a row fishing
plankton, invisible animals.
You fish.
You don't see what you fish.
But you fish every
day for four years--
crazy, crazy, you think.
You're really crazy guys.
Of course, when you fish
plankton across the ocean,
you fish a lot of plastic.
And this is one of the main
disasters we're facing today.
This is a reversible disaster.
If we do something,
we will stop that.
But this is a very
important disaster.
And we also spent
a lot of time--
right now, the boat
is at the middle
of this two-year
expedition in the Pacific.
She was this morning in Kimbe
Bay in Papua, New Guinea,
getting ready for a new survey
in this part of the island.
We study the coral
reef ecosystem
over all the Pacific for
two and a half years.
This is now.
Back, 10 years ago, we
studied the Arctic Ocean.
This is North Pole.
This is the Arctic region.
And you can see the
North Pole here.
And this was done
by a guy, crazy guy,
who wanted to be the first
guy at the North Pole
a century before called Nansen.
He missed his goal, but we did
the same track, the only one
to do it, 10 years ago.
And we drifted across the
Arctic Ocean doing science--
now, we'll not go into
details-- but took measurements
everywhere, down in the water,
in the atmosphere, on the ice.
We did six months of dark--
in the dark six months.
This expedition lasted
a year and a half.
Six months in the dark,
nonstop, pushed by the winds,
the ice is crossing
the ocean-- we did
5,000 kilometers doing nothing.
The world of Tara, this
world that you see here,
is drifting 10 kilometers
per day in the Arctic,
pushed by the prevailing winds.
And if you look at how it works,
it's like tectonic plates.
We can have the sound
here maybe in the--
put up the volume, please.
And the plates in the Arctic,
they move not the same speed.
And sometimes, they
crush the boat.
This is real time.
And nothing we do in our
planet can stop that.
The energy of the
Arctic is colossal.
[CLICKING SOUNDS]
This world is drifting
10 kilometers per day.
So you study that,
and you sit there.
It is six months day, six months
dark, and six months day again.
And this was 10 years ago.
Big achievements-- we
changed crew members.
We change scientists.
We do rotation,
logistic rotation,
to get the press people
on board and to tell
the story of the Arctic--
and then, again, fun unites.
This was done 10 years ago.
And then, back from this
upper North Pole area,
we said OK, what's
going to be the fate
of this ecosystem, the ocean
system, in a changing climate?
What would be the future?
What can we understand?
This is plankton.
This is drifting
across the ocean
everywhere-- billions and
billions of organisms.
Colomban will talk to
you more about that.
So we went to study this
ecosystem across the planet
for four years on this track.
And we collected.
In every stop, we stopped and
we corrected fished plankton
ecosystem, the world ecosystem.
In the same way,
repeating, always
the same kitchen on board,
the same infiltration--
very boring.
But you cannot imagine the
enthusiasm you can see on board
of this voyage, because the
people believe that they were
doing something that
was completely new.
Like Colomban says
very often, it's
like being in the
rainforest with the nets,
catching birds and new things.
So this was a crazy project,
including the Arctic ocean.
And Colomban will talk to
you more about this science
and this knowledge.
We did study the
ecosystem completely--
bacteria, viruses,
organisms, algaes.
We call it protist.
He's a crazy protist
man, Colomban.
Now, we are trying to
understand all this behavior.
This is the fish
food that we talk
about-- fish food, the
fish they eat that,
and they rely on that.
So far, we did a lot of data.
It's a big ocean data.
We got ocean life data,
molecular data, genomics,
images, legal data
on every sample,
because we were many
times in countries
that owns these organisms.
And we have other connectivity
with data centers.
And this huge data is
one of the biggest,
and the first time we describe
an ecosystem completely
as a whole--
the first time ever it is done.
And Colomban will talk
to you about that.
And these scientists we work
with across the world, 25
laboratories from 10 countries,
they did publish in "Science,"
did the cover of
"Science" two years ago.
And this was the start of a
crazy adventure in science,
and it's still ongoing
now even if we come back
from this trip six years ago.
Doing that, you fish
all these organisms.
But also you fish a lot
of plastic, plastic bits
that is degrading into
the ocean and that
is catching all the
life of the ocean.
It's also sticking
to it like a rock.
It's nice to be at the sun
for algaes, enjoy this sun,
make their life.
And they are drifting
across the ocean like that.
This is a simulation for
the Mediterranean Sea.
You drop on the
model of the Med,
you drop 10 particles in every
of these four main rivers.
And you wait for a year
to see how are they going.
This is a trimester.
This is six months--
10 particles every day a year.
This is about to be 3/4.
You can see that
particles on the road
are going up to Alexandria at
the end of the year-- which
is completely crazy how what
we do on land, what we do
in our cities, in our
daily life, the impact
we can have on the
ocean and its life.
And you can see different
patterns, different streams
across the Mediterranean Sea--
just to show you the impact.
So we did a crazy
seven months journey
in the Mediterranean Sea.
We collected these
plastic things
over seven months,
300 locations.
And we are now
still studying them.
Coming back from
this expedition,
one of the main ecosystems on
the planet besides plankton--
in terms of biodiversity
of the ocean,
that is storing a
lot of biodiversity,
30% of the biodiversity--
is linked to coral reefs.
Very small places, but huge
diversity, huge ecosystem,
huge biomass as well.
So we decided to put
Tara for 2 and 1/2 years
on an expedition to
study over the same,
over the same samples, repeated
work over the 2 and 1/2 years
to sample the reef,
its surrounding waters,
the organisms, the animals.
And I can show you here
the video-- please--
a crazy video showing you
the super micro activity
of coral reef.
You're going to
see it's beautiful.
And you will understand the
issues with garbage today.
We will talk a lot about
bleaching reefs to get white.
But first, look at the
beauty of these organisms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we have divers up top
diving in many, many places.
So far, we did 20 states.
These are states, small states.
Now, if you look into details,
this is 10 centimeters.
This is a millimeter.
This is coral.
This is an animal.
It's like a jellyfish upside
down fixed on the rock,
and it's feeding,
and it's sleeping.
They are like us.
They have bones inside.
Corals are incredible.
You can see these guys
getting out at night usually.
They like that you
do not see them.
And so they feed--
this is the mouth.
This is an animal.
They feed.
The color you see
here is an algae
they have in the body
that are giving them
90% of the sugar they need to
live, 10% of what they eat.
And when there is too much
stress, too much temperature,
too high, they get white.
The algae is going away.
And if it lasts too
long, the animal
maybe is starving and dies.
And then it's completely covered
by sea grass in the ocean.
This is climate change.
This is what we talk about
now everywhere, every year.
Even in very remote places--
this is 4,000 kilometers
from any towns in the world.
[INAUDIBLE] All white.
So this is not a direct impact.
This is really a global impact.
And today, we have
very few understanding
of what's going on,
how the Scar Reef
is behaving, what other
mechanisms-- the process inside
to resist climate change,
to resist pollution.
And we were used to
main El Nino events
of warming of the
Pacific every six,
seven years over
the last 50 years.
And for the last three
years, every year,
we find we can see
bleaching events.
Sometimes they
recover, and the reef
is getting back to its states.
And sometimes it's too hard.
And they don't recover.
So this will not disappear.
But the reef will change--
how they will change?
The system will change.
The species will
adapt and change.
How it will change, what will be
the fate of this in the future,
we don't know.
And it's very important
for our states,
because reef is tourism,
economy, fisheries, protection
against storms, et cetera.
So the drawing now is like that.
We are here now in
Kimbe Bay, this place.
We have still a lot
to go and come back
in France in October,
in a year, October 2018.
Kind of pictures of
working down below,
another picture of a
very kind boy here.
And there you can see that
we are sampling the reef.
We are getting plankton
off of the reef
to see which are the
interactions of this.
And this-- we are doing
that every day also.
So it's a hard life.
It's a hard life.
They work a lot.
They work a lot and a
lot every day on board.
They complain a lot,
because they work too much.
But they do an
amazing, amazing job.
And policy-wise, this
project is enough,
both science, outreach,
public, easy to understand,
kids are on board.
That is very, kind
of, a bizarre project
that is attracting
Ban Ki-moon twice
on board Tara in
New York in 2012.
And he come to talk
to anyone in Paris.
The boat was in Paris, downtown.
And he came again
on board with us.
And this guy, Eric Karsenti, and
agnes b. was our main backers,
but also, Eric Karsenti
was one of the main thinker
of this plankton project
that Colomban will talk
to you about it in a while.
Education is key.
And I will not go
long about that,
because I am short of time.
But everywhere the boat
goes, we get people on board.
When we came in Paris,
there were 10,000 kids
come on board with the schools.
We do pitches.
We do talks in the schools.
We try to explain them what
we talk about, what we do,
give them the feel of the ocean.
And everybody is doing it--
the scientist, the sailors--
everyone.
This is really a great,
great time-- good energy,
good shot of energy.
And the next is, of course,
the science going on.
And Colomban will talk
to you about that.
So in the future,
we're going to go again
in the Arctic Ocean in 2020.
We are developing
now a polar station,
pretty big polar station, to
put some scientists on the ice,
and to understand how this
Arctic Ocean is affecting
our climate, to understand what
sleeps below the ocean, what
is the life there.
Nobody knows about it.
Nobody has a clue about it.
And this will be in 2020.
And this device should
drift across the Arctic
Ocean for the next 20
years as we plan to do it.
So it's going to
be a long journey
and will be the only manned
station in the Arctic then.
Thank you very much.
And I welcome Colomban
to come on board.
[APPLAUSE]
So fasten your seat
belt, because you're
going to hear science now.
So stay calm.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: OK.
ROMAIN TROUBLE:
Breathe normally.
And of course, I
would like thank
the backers of this project,
the scientific backers.
Those are the
private backers that
is involved in these
projects since 10 years.
Thank you.
Colomban, the floor is yours.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: Thank you
for the nice introduction.
OK, so I'm Colomban.
I am not a sailor, but I
am a Swiss oceanographer.
And I was very lucky to meet,
actually, Romain and also
this person that Romain
mentioned already,
Eric Karsenti.
I'm not sure if this
is working or not.
Yeah, it works.
So Eric is an amazing cell
biologist from the EMBL.
He spent, like, 30
years of his life trying
to understand how cell auto--
you know, cell divides.
And how all molecules
within the cell
take a shape and auto-organize.
So it's the science
of self-organization
using statistics,
mechanics, you know,
and so it's really that
the shaping of life
with the element of life.
And when I met Eric, he
showed me this movie,
which is a zebrafish.
So you can see here all the
cell of a little fish dividing.
So it's a real fish
under a spin microscope.
And you can see this baby fish
taking shape under your eyes--
single-- all the cells.
So it's just amazing,
and it was the beginning
of spin microscopy.
And so this is really
self-organization
of an organism.
And when Eric showed me this
in 2007, I was thinking, OK,
I should follow this guy.
And I should-- and Eric,
besides being an amazing--
so he did all this in his lab.
They developed the
best microscope.
And Eric, he's a great sailor.
He's an amazing sailor, but
he never looked in the ocean--
of the life in the ocean.
But he was brave
enough to think, OK,
let's try to understand
the ocean that way.
And that's always
what we had in mind.
So basically, we are--
today, we are really entering
this era of ecosystems.
And we don't see any organisms
anymore as a single organism
but as an ecosystem and
mainly human body, right?
You know, there are millions
now of euros and dollars spent
to understand how many
microbial genes-- because we
are many more microbial genes
in our body than human genes.
We have only 25,000 human genes.
We have many more
bacterial cells
than human cells in our body.
So today, we really see
the human as an ecosystem.
And so we start to want to
map all the cells of human.
I don't know if you have heard
about this new project called
Human Cell Atlas, which is
actually funded, essentially,
by Zuckerberg, by the
Facebook Foundation.
Now we have the technology
to sequence single cell of--
the genome of single cells,
of the expressed genes
of single cell.
And the idea here is
to map all the cells,
because we don't even know
how many different cells we
have in the human body.
But each-- all the cells
take different shape.
Based on the same genome,
they take different shape.
And they make ourselves, right?
So we really have this
ecosystemic vision of human.
And in fact, what
we forget often--
and this is very interesting.
This is a human cell.
This is a macrophage.
You have this cell
in your blood now.
You have thousands of
these cells in your body
hunting for bacteria.
You have here the leukocyte.
It's another type of cell.
And this cell has just
eaten-- so it's cleaning
your body out of bacteria.
So it's really your ecosystem.
And what is fascinating--
sorry, I was too fast--
is that, in fact, if
you go to the ocean,
you can see this kind of
cell that's an amoeba,
for instance, you know,
hunting for microalgae
here-- microalgae.
And the resemblance is amazing.
And in fact, you
know, the composition
in salt between your
blood and the ocean
is strictly almost the same.
The content of salt
is almost the same.
The proportion is
different, but we are really
a walking piece of ocean.
And so I think--
so the origin of life,
you know, is in the ocean.
All these organisms have
invented all the genes we have
and all the shape we
have in our cells.
And so we really
need to understand
these systems, which is much
more complex than human,
of course.
So what we decided
in 2008 was really
to jump into the big bath and
to go to this, like Romain said,
to this global ocean, which,
in every liter of seawater,
you have between 10 and 100
billion organisms, including
viruses, in every liter.
And the ocean
generates all this.
It's actually not a blue planet.
It's a blue-green planet.
You have all this
green here, which
is photosynthetic
cells, like the tree,
but single-cell organisms,
which produce half of the oxygen
that we breathe on the planet.
The ocean is also extremely
reactive to global change.
So it will feedback
on climate very fast.
So we really need to
understand how this feedback--
the resilience of
the system, and how
it will give us an answer to
what we pose to planet Earth.
So we decided basically to, in
this era of ecosystems biology,
to--
so Eric spent 30 years on
this, billions of euros.
Now there are many,
many projects on this.
It's also billions of dollars.
So we decided to go directly to
this one, to the full system--
planet Earth, the
biggest system.
And the advantage of this system
over classical system that we
know, ecosystem that we
know better-- maybe as kids,
you know, because we
see these systems--
is that in these ecosystems,
organisms are very big.
So it's very difficult
to sample these systems.
A forest, it's impossible
to sample trees.
And also the dynamic of these
ecosystems is very slow.
The climax of-- the
life of a forest
is bigger than a human
life, while in the plankton,
you have a bit of everything.
You have, you will see,
you have a bit of all life,
but it's changing.
It's reorganizing.
Like the fish, you know--
during the highlight I
showed the baby fish--
it's all the time reorganizing.
So we think we can understand
fundamental principle
of ecosystemics.
So the beauty of
plankton, as I said,
is that you don't have the
10th orders of magnitude
across which life develop.
It stops, basically,
at a few centimeters.
And so we developed a
protocol to sample plankton
from viruses to bacteria,
to protists, to animals.
And there is no plants,
because photosynthesis
is done by these protists.
We put on the boat--
so it was crazy,
because it was in 2008.
We had very little
time to equip the boat.
What was fantastic
that we started
was the flexibility, the
reactivity, which you can never
do in classical-- in academia.
So we equipped the lab.
And we were very lucky,
because it was just
the beginning of the high
throughput sequencing
with the Illumina method.
So it was just the time
where the price of sequencing
was dropping terribly.
And so we had different
nets and pumps
to sample this-- for plankton.
We also had a very
nice rosette, which
is an instrument to measure all
kinds of underwater parameters.
So I will tell you about
the data we collected.
We collected data in omics,
so basically, DNA and RNA
expressed genes.
Just for the people
who like data,
we collected about 900
billion Illumina DNA reads.
That's more than 90
terabases raw DNA data
from seven
organismal-size fractions,
from viruses to animals, and
from about more than 4,000
plankton communities.
Yeah, this is just again
the number of data,
the number of computing
time we have used for now,
and the number of analyses
that we have done.
And as you can see, it's--
by far, it's two-time-- twice--
100 times higher than the
next project in ocean systems
ecology.
So it's really the biggest--
by far the biggest ecosystemic
project in the ocean.
What is very hard in
ecology is to collect
homogeneous data,
standardized data
across sufficient
spatiotemporal scale.
So this is for the DNA data.
And then we-- this
is very original.
We used a lot of instruments.
Flow cytometry-- this
one, we developed.
And I will tell you a few
words about this one--
FlowCAM, ZooScan, and UVP--
to image, as well, the plankton.
So we took a lot of
images of those organisms
at the same site at
a different depth.
And so this was this--
we haven't almost
touched the data.
You know, it's very--
and so we got--
for now, we have six
million images of plankton.
A lot of them are already
validated by experts.
And we have-- yeah,
which represent more
than 330 terabytes of data.
We also have done a
website, which I think--
an instrument on the web,
an online image platform
to basically share this
image project-by-project
with experts.
Because we need a
semi-automated machine learning
processes to learn the machine
to recognize the images.
And so there is
no, you know-- also
there is a gene bank for genes.
There is international
banks for genes.
There is nothing equivalent for
images in ecology in science.
So it's really something
that we need to think about.
OK, time-- now let's get
into the data itself.
So it will be a bit harder.
So we publish this wonderful
special issue in "Science."
And of course, we have now--
I think we have published
150 papers since 2009.
It's hard to speak
about it in 10 minutes.
But what we can
say from this data,
I think, here the three
papers concerned viruses,
the bacteria, and eukaryotes.
Eukaryotes are us--
cells with a nucleus.
And what is amazing--
you don't need to look
at the detail, but--
is that we saturate
many of these diversity.
Meaning that the
more we sequence,
the less we find new things.
And basically, we sampled
the ocean largely enough,
the surface of the ocean--
and this was just from
the surface--
to basically not see
anymore anything new.
So we push the
diversity very far away.
We sequenced 40 million
protein-coding genes
for bacteria.
But we see most of them,
which is fantastic.
So we see the limit
of this diversity.
So we can start to think
in terms of ecosystemics.
There is just one compartment
that we didn't saturate,
and this is the eukaryotes,
eukaryotic cells,
like ourselves.
We sequence more and more,
and there is many more new.
So we are now reaching 150
million eukaryotic genes
in this plankton.
And it's endless.
We are far from saturation.
In fact, most of these
genes are unknown.
They don't look anything
that we have in the database.
And the other one, we can't just
attach them to known things,
but it's very unsure yet.
So this is really amazing.
And in fact, I think we are--
just to show you
an example of what
we can see now with image data
with using these instruments.
We just take a picture
of the marine snow.
The marine snow is
all these organisms
that fall down to the
bottom of the ocean,
and which is actually the
mechanism that maintains also
the atmosphere we breathe.
With this instrument,
we learned--
we teach the instrument--
I mean, the data--
to recognize this
kind of shape, which
correspond to giant protists.
And we realized that these
giant protists in fact
have a bigger biomass than
all animals in the plankton,
in the subtropical and
tropical regime here.
And they look like that.
No one knows these
Rhizaria, these [INAUDIBLE]..
I think there was,
like, something
like 90 species described.
These guys are
running the world.
If you dive in there in
the middle of the ocean,
you will see tons of these
little guys floating.
They are beautiful creatures
in symbiosis with algae-like--
or they are a bit
like piece of corals
floating around the world.
I think we are almost coming
to a new theory of life
of biological diversity.
For a long time we
thought that life was--
for three centuries-- that
life was in animals and plants,
and the diversity was
decreasing toward microbes.
Then over the last few years,
over the last three decades,
because they started--
people started
to sequence the
small animals, we
saw that the diversity was
in the viruses and bacteria.
And now that we have a real
ecosystemic view of our system,
we see that there is
a peak of diversity
of genes of organisms
in the middle,
like, between a few
microns and 15 microns.
That's where, really,
life has complexified.
And no one has studied this
piece of life, you know?
So we speak about diversity.
Now we know that
diversity is there.
And we actually have sequenced--
we went to the Amazon Forest.
And it's the same.
You find this peak
of life, which
I call life's middle class,
lower-middle class, in fact.
So these organisms
look like that.
They are my obsession a bit--
protists.
So at least I want you
to remember this name.
And so protists are beautiful
creatures, single-celled.
So they have very
complex genomes.
They can build
beautiful skeletons.
Here you have some
coccolithophores.
This is always one cell.
This is one cell building.
So the cell is living inside.
And it's building up
these little plates
and assembling them
outside the cell.
You can see how these
cells are powerful.
This is actually
one of the cells
building the plate inside the--
inside some vesicle and
extruding the plates.
This cell is the most
calcifying organism on Earth.
You can see it--
the cell [INAUDIBLE] the
Black Sea here, in summer,
at some time of the year.
And these cells-- so
for instance, this cell
is at the same time a
plant and an animal.
It can eat.
It can photosynthesize.
It can build this marvelous
nanotechnology pieces
and transform the Earth
system, as you can
see from the geological record.
The shore of Dover here is of
100% coccolithophore, almost.
So they have an impact, a
major impact, probably stronger
than the one we have,
actually, today.
So with protist,
a new world that
is now coming into the
game of global ecology--
and now what we want to try
also to do a lot is to assemble
all these complex data.
So we have different
layers of data.
We have ecological data.
We have genomes, genes,
organisms, and satellite data
as well.
So we have different
heterogeneous complex data
that we try to put together
with graph-based methods.
And so we did this paper.
We built up the first
global plankton interactome.
And what we saw is that biotic
interactions are more important
abiotic interactions, and
that there are much more
taxon-taxon interaction
in this network
rather than
taxon-environmental parameters.
And that corporation,
positive relation,
are much more important
than exclusive relation,
which is kind of a nice
lesson, I think, of life.
And now you can analyze this.
It's going to take years
to understand really
what functions are
driving these networks,
these big ecological networks.
What we have found for instance
is that, in fact, parasites
are incredibly abundant
but nice parasites.
These parasites try
not to kill their host,
because they need their host.
So parasitism seems to be a
big driver of the stability
of the network.
In fact, we know as
humans that we don't
have enough parasites probably.
Now there is a medicine that
think that we should get back
our parasites to be healthier.
We also started to
basically use this network,
because this network
is really the ecology
of a complex system-- plankton.
Now we try also to mix it
to other complex systems,
like biogeochemical cycles,
like the carbon pump, which
is a very important fundamental
mechanism of the biosphere
or climate processes.
So in this paper,
we try to extract
the most important component
of the network, which are not
often the most abundant.
Often they are the
most connected.
Two fundamental
processes of the carbon
flux that we measured with this
instrument I showed you before,
the UVP, Underwater
Video Profiler.
And we found that specific
plankton communities correlate
with carbon export, in
particular, with radiolarians,
dinoflagellates,
and synechococcus
is very important--
different species.
And we can predict
actually the carbon export
with part of these networks
at a very high accuracy.
So now where are we?
I think we need to
have a job, I think.
I think we had about--
because we sample, you know,
220 sites, three depths, and
so we have about, I think,
600 ecosystem in this
global body of the ocean.
But the ocean is super complex.
It's super dynamic.
You have a lot of connection.
You have this big
gyre, who have, like,
300 kilometers large.
And it take them three
years to cross the Atlantic.
And so we need, of
course, more expedition.
And we need to
expand the approach
we have on very clever
temporal and spatial scales.
So Romain told you about--
so now we have a new project
today, which is called
TO-SEE, Tara Oceans Systems
Ecology and Evolution,
where we try to-- this
is the data I just showed you.
This is what I call now the
symbiome, made of bacteria,
of protists, and animals,
metabolists, shapes,
and behavior.
We have a new
project, basically,
is to expand the
approach we have done
over different spatiotemporal
scales that will allow
us to understand the system.
One very important aspect is
there is an incredibly good
platform to develop
new protocols
and to do very, very
actually hardcore science.
But there is also between
10 and 15,000 sailing boats
at any time in the ocean
crossing the ocean.
And we started to transfer part
of the best protocol we have
done to these sailors, which
we call now the Plankton odes
in this Plankton Planet project.
We have basically
extracted a little protocol
to collect plankton very
easily, and a little kit that
allows them to get
a little plankton,
and send us through the--
actually, they dry the plankton.
And they send us just
a galette of plankton
to the lab directly.
And we could show--
it was just a test
phase as a case study,
but it was actually quite--
it was super-easy to find
enough sailors.
I mean, we had too many people
that wanted to participate.
We had 25 crews who sailed
the planet in one year.
And we could collect data
from all these dots here,
these regimes.
Here is the number of samples,
different boats collecting
plankton.
And we got all this data.
And we sequenced it for
barcoding-- for DNA barcode.
And here you can see, in red,
the number of new plankton
genus that we never found in
our-- in this big data set
I showed you, showing
that, in fact, we
are reaching saturation, but
there is a lot to discover.
And if we want to reach
a very fine granularity,
we need these boat to help.
Because there is
no automated way
yet of sampling the
complexity of the ocean.
The last point I wanted
to say is that we
need to develop imaging.
And we have developed
a fantastic approach
to automatically image,
thanks to Eric Karsenti,
and to come back to the
beginning of my talk.
We developed these new methods--
this method that was
used in human biology--
to do automatic, 3D,
high resolution imaging,
confocal, of all the
cells that I showed you.
And it's beautiful, because
you can really scan the cell
through it's three dimensions.
See the chloroplast,
the nucleus, the shape,
the membrane systems.
You can then print the
cells, which is beautiful,
because you can show them.
This is plankton
for blind people.
You can really show them.
It's very important.
This cell, you know, it's one of
the most abundant on the planet
Earth, right?
And so it's so cool to
have it in your hand.
And actually, I will give you--
you can pass it if you want.
And now we need to--
and also, you can see
all this symbiosis
that these cells are made of.
All the cells are congregates,
are little ecosystems.
There are ecosystems
within the ecosystems.
So we can study the--
here you can see
some cyanobacteria,
which are the cells that
give the chloroplasts, which
are living in symbiosis with
some of these organisms.
So we can start to understand
fundamental process
of evolution of this system.
The dream is this--
is to really understand the
rules of evolution, functioning
ecology, of one biome
on earth, and basically
to understand how
different models we have,
their stability,
their resilience.
If we don't understand
this, we will never
be able to predict, accurately,
climate, or the future of our--
us human body.
We totally depend
on the biosphere.
And there is this guy at
MIT, Mick Follows, that
does some beautiful
modeling, including physics
and chemistry of the world.
He's really a genius.
But the problem is there
is no data, basically.
We have the models.
Everything is working.
We just need to include
the complexity of life.
So I think it's maybe
another 15, 20 years.
And we will be there.
Since 50 years, we know that
we have to understand this one.
This is really-- because, I
mean, it's stronger than Earth.
The dynamics of the
Earth's community
will hit the dynamics
of the Earth system.
And it will-- the Earth system
is much stronger than we are.
That's for sure.
So we have to learn how to live
in symbiosis with Mrs. Earth,
which contain all actually.
So I want to thank
very much this little--
this was really a first,
very emotional, picture
of the beginning
of the crews, who
is Eric Karsenti,
of course, Romain.
You have also Chris Bowler--
Etienne Bourgois, who used
to be the owner of Tara.
Now it belong to
the Foundation--
and myself, and,
well, it was really
the little first nucleus.
And thank you very much
to you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: All right,
thanks very much, guys.
It was an incredibly interesting
talk, some amazing information,
amazing visuals, amazing data.
We're going to open up the
floor for some questions
from Googlers.
There is a couple of
mics at the back there.
If you have any questions,
and you would like
to go up and bring them forth.
I have a first question.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: Are
you still on board?
Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: I'm going to open
it up with the first question.
When I see the imagery
of all that amazing kind
of sea life, the plethora of all
these different kind of colors
and things, it's incredible.
And then I see the imagery
of all the coral bleaching.
And it's just really,
really impactful.
What, in your opinion, can
me, as a person, and me,
as a Googler, do to
help with your cause?
ROMAIN TROUBLE:
What you could do?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: There is
a very simple thing to do.
I think the problem with ecology
is that since decades we tell
people that we have no time.
It's too late.
The fate is over, or we have--
I think that we really
lose a lot of people
who don't want to see.
If there is no time
to do something,
you better not want to see it,
because otherwise you panic.
That's really the panic.
And I believe that the change
we need in the society,
as a whole, is to
change behavior.
And this will take generations.
And that's, I believe--
OK, we have a lot of
stress on our planet now.
We have a lot of,
as you can see,
a lot of stress
on the ecosystems.
I believe we have the
time to think ahead.
As long as we plan, as
long as we know what to do,
as long as we do science
to understand this planet,
I believe that we
have time to change
in the future generation.
What you buy every day--
when you buy something,
you have a huge power
on the future economy.
The way you buy things,
good things, bad things,
healthy things, bad
for environment,
bad for the pollution--
really, a choice
is very important.
The second thing you
can do is very cheap.
It's free, actually.
If you have kids,
you tell the kids--
you try to put them some
consciousness about all this--
not the details of course,
but this planet is our land,
is our home.
How can we do things
better in the future?
It is easy.
And this is, like, also a
trigger for questioning,
a trigger for innovating,
changing the way we did before,
change this way for what we
are going to do tomorrow.
And of course, the third thing
you can do is when you vote.
I don't ask you to
vote for ecologists,
but keeping in mind this, what
they have to say on ecology.
But of course, don't vote
always for ecologists.
I'm not really ecology's fan.
But keep in mind what they
propose on this aspect.
This is the way we're going to
change, slowly, the trajectory.
And I think this is--
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: The fifth.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: The
ocean is very resilient.
Colomban?
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: The fifth
and very important thing,
as a Google engineer, you
can help us, basically.
We have layers of complex
heterogeneous data--
global.
We have genomes, expressed
genes, organisms, images.
Then you have the
satellite images
also that you can connect.
So there is a lot
of-- it's big data.
So our dream is
to have a Google--
Tara Google ocean platform,
or something, in giant.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: This is
due to Google networks--
the same.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: We really--
actually, we are
unable, us, to do that,
because we are too few people.
And so if you can help us
to do that, and also to--
so there is big data--
exploring the big data first.
And then there is artificial
intelligence for teaching,
for instance, the satellite
to recognize gene diversity,
or some--
you can imagine a lot of things.
And I think this is a very good
use of artificial intelligence
for global ecology,
probably maybe the best
use of artificial intelligence.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: And if
you work really hard,
you may have a chance
to sail on board--
work really hard.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS:
So we need you.
That's for sure.
ROMAIN TROUBLE:
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
Hi.
Over here on your right.
Mark in the back.
SPEAKER 1: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
This was really fascinating.
And it seems like
you're straddling lots
of world sailing and science.
I wanted to ask
about, generally,
how you're being supported.
It sounds like you have some
private support from companies
and individuals but
also public support.
The French government,
especially,
seem very interested
to follow your work.
Could you speak a little
bit about especially how
governments are helping you and
what they're doing to help you?
ROMAIN TROUBLE: Oh, it's
a real ecosystem as well.
We have donators
like you and I giving
$10 a day per some time,
per month, or whatever.
We have big donors.
We have corporate
foundations for French
corporate, Swedish, American,
and Japanese so far.
Corporations who
contribute in sponsorship.
They don't have any
clue what we do,
don't have any rights
on what we collect.
It's really sponsorship
for knowledge.
We also work with
connectivities, cities,
like Lyons, Brittany.
In France, we are pretty
well supported by the states.
And over the last
10 years, since we
are with Colomban
working on this project,
Colomban is working at the CNRS.
It's a state laboratory.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: Like a
postier or, you know, I am--
ROMAIN TROUBLE: Like a postier,
like a-- yeah, a postman.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: No, this
the beauty of the CNRS system.
It's super stable.
So we have a few people
totally fascinated
by this product in the CNRS,
in the French states, who
are going-- not going to stop.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: So they are
supporting this project.
They put already $20 million in
the research with the [FRENCH],,
with many, many, many
different aspects.
But we don't-- we
always need more.
And we changed the way
we do science before.
So this is innovation.
Innovation is risky.
And sometimes it is hard to get
funding for risky innovations.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: In a sense,
I think the beginning of this
started because we were
a few people with totally
stable work.
You know, I cannot be
fired even if I don't work.
And so there were
people like me.
And then the private
company, you know,
and Etienne Bourgois, and
agnes b., who were supporting.
So this mix between hyper
stability and private funding
founders make this
actually start.
It would have been
very hard to start
this with classical academic--
ROMAIN TROUBLE: You know,
France took the leadership.
The French State took the
leadership at the COP 21
on climate.
We did a lot.
France invested a lot
in diplomacy about that.
And what we do now, we
started to also teach
that, OK, the planet,
the climate, we barely
understand it.
What's going to be
the fate of the ocean?
How this would be a reaction?
What will be the future?
And this is the next
step of the COP 21
is really to better
understand this ecosystem
that you see here.
COLOMBAN DE VARGAS: In
2013, when we came back,
we got French [FRENCH] funding,
which allowed us to organize,
to produce most of the
data, and organize it.
ROMAIN TROUBLE: And Cedric
Villani was here with us today,
because we are doing
now-- working now
is it artificial intelligence.
We have so much data
that we need to dig into.
And this is the
beginning of a new story.
And I hope that Google will be
with us on that at some stage.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: All right,
guys, thanks very much.
I'm afraid we're--
ROMAIN TROUBLE: Good luck.
SPEAKER 1: --we're out of time.
Yeah, again, big round
of applause for Tara.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.